hello welcome to my house please come in
honor Gunners daughter's bungalow in a
suburb of the Icelandic capital
Reykjavik is a modern concrete looking
villa with a previous life like almost
all the houses here it was built in the
1960s Anna and her husband have
modernized the bungalow and renovated it
in keeping with its surroundings
I enjoyed to stay here and all the
lights and the nature to be in contact
with the nature here gets very much
balance between inside and outside yeah
it's very you feel very good connection
and relaxed here the idea for the
conversion came about in 2015 at first
Anna
only wanted to redesign the kitchen and
dining room
but that led to a total conversion now
there is plenty of room for Anna and her
husband and their daughter who often
visits the first time we started really
to to break things down it's like a
journey you don't know where to where
you going because we never thought it
was so much as it turned out to be I
have to say that because it was always
more and more and more and but it was
also fun to do it hardly anything
remains of the old house this special
furnishing was the idea of a
construction worker during the
renovation he had cut the one piece out
of the bathroom wall to make a window
and and from this piece he cut this out
and got the idea to make this lap and
this is really the only piece from the
old house that reminds me of it it's
these legs
the spacious open living space with many
small cozy corners is a new feature it
includes a TV corner in the heart of the
house
an office space in the rear
there is a room with a fireplace on the
lower level the furnishings are a mix of
souvenirs and functional furniture when
it comes to interior design on a places
great importance on quality and
continuity I think it's good to keep
some old pieces all Sofia for for the
past for the memories of the past you
have Ana's bungalow has 345 square
metres of indoor living space
remodeling instead of building a new
proved the right decision in addition
there is the newly designed outdoor area
with a typical Icelandic thermal bath I
was happy with my house before and so I
work just wanted to have anyway yeah I
think use from the house what you can
and then you break the other things and
make them as you want to have it the
best of both a mix of old and new both
classical and modern the bungalow is now
exactly the home on a goodish daughter
always wanted